bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors il serait le premier
pays à utiliser largement sa population
contre le coc vie premier pays à lancer
une campagne de rappel ont beau
aujourd'hui la mise en place de la
troisième dose qui est devenu
obligatoire ans pour bénéficier du pass
vert certains diront que les autorités
israéliennes vont un peu trop vite en
besogne
quelle est votre position là dessus
écoutez je crois que c'est très clair à
partir du moment où nous avons
maintenant une grande hélas période
d'observation a donc les scientifiques
voient très bien comment les choses se
déroulent nous avons en israël une
situation avec le nouveau variant
premièrement qui est beaucoup plus
agressive que la forme initiale
deuxièmement la durée de protection des
vaccins classiques et moins grande
vis-à-vis de ce nouveau variant et
troisièmement cette résistance a donné
par les vaccins est différente d'un
fournisseur de vaccins à l'autre donc il
ya vraiment une nécessité
je dirais rationnel scientifique de se
protéger et d'augmenter effectivement le
taux de protection individuelle par
cette troisième dose c'est une mesure
stratégique et il faut accepter que les
stratégies bouge parce que le virus lui
bouge aussi beaucoup n'est ce pas alors
des manifestations se sont tenues un
j'aime le dire pour dénoncer cette
nouvelle mesure est ce que le pouvoir et
je reviens le nouveau pour voir
d'ailleurs ce n'est en danger
pas du tout vous savez vous qu'il est
facile de mettre une caméra devant des
manifestants à il est beaucoup plus
difficile en france ou en israël 1 de
mettre une caméra devant des millions de
gens qui sont d'accord avec la stratégie
donc je crois qu'il faut être très très
prudent avec les manifestations qui se
produise car elles sont relativement je
dirais à faible il ya
82 % de la population française qui est
vaccinée pour les plus de 18 ans n'est
ce pas donc voilà il faudrait beaucoup
de caméra n'est ce pas pour
pouvoir filmer tous ces gens et il ya
besoin d'une caméra pour filmer une
manifestation
gérard vespière merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
fondateurs du web magazine le monde
décrypté marcia bout